Alexander Fleming: Father of Antibiotics
Scientists are not exactly the most well-known
people in the world, and yet there are a few
names among them which have established themselves
firmly in the public consciousness.
Alexander Fleming is one of those names, inexorably
linked with the discovery of penicillin.
Even people who have never studied science
or medicine in their lives may have still
heard the story of how Fleming’s messiness
accidentally yielded the first antibiotic
in the world.
How he left behind in his lab some Petri dishes
with bacterial cultures and, when he came
back, one of them developed mold which killed
the bacteria and the rest, as they say, is
history.
Well, maybe not just yet.
As we are about to discover, the real story
was a lot longer and more complicated and
definitely involved a lot more people.
History might have preferred to condense it
down to one manageable, bitesize chunk, but
today, however, we are looking at the full
course meal.
Early Years & Education
Alexander Fleming came from humble beginnings.
He was born on August 6, 1881, at Lochfield
Farm near the small town of Darvel in Ayrshire,
Scotland.
He was the seventh of eight children of Hugh
Fleming, with the last four coming from his
second marriage to Grace Stirling Morton.
Fleming’s father was a farmer.
His mother came from a farming family.
He grew up on a large, remote 800-acre farm
that was a mile away from the nearest house.
He and his siblings spent their earliest years
roaming through the nearby valleys, streams,
and moors, ensuring that the future man of
science will always have a fondness and respect
for nature.
The family suffered a major setback in 1888
when Hugh Fleming passed away.
His eldest son from his first marriage took
over the day-to-day operations of the farm.
As for Alexander Fleming, or Alec, as the
rest of the family called him, he began his
education at Louden Moor School, a small place
that only had a dozen or so students of different
ages who were all taught in the same classroom.
From there, he moved on to Darvel School which
was a bit more advanced, but required young
Alec to walk eight miles each day.
It did not take long for other people to recognize
Fleming’s academic potential and, at age
11, he was awarded a scholarship to Kilmarnock
Academy, a state-funded secondary school and
only one of two schools in the whole United
Kingdom (the other being the prestigious Eton
College) which had educated two Nobel Prize
laureates.
Fleming spent two years at this academy but,
when he was 13, he got the opportunity to
continue his studies in London.
One of his older brothers, Tom, had moved
to the city to study medicine and later opened
a practice there.
Soon enough, four of his younger siblings,
Alec included, joined him and lived together
in London.
Fleming enrolled in the Royal Polytechnic
Institution where, again, he impressed with
his book-learning and acumen.
He was skipped ahead two years and finished
school when he was just 16.
From there, he needed a job and found work
with a shipping office.
He spent four years at that place, but later
recalled that he did not enjoy the experience.
Going to Med School
In 1900, Alec found a much-needed break from
the work he disliked by joining two of his
brothers in the Second Boer War in South Africa.
All were part of a Volunteer infantry unit
called the London Scottish Regiment.
However, they never actually saw any action
before the war ended and mostly spent their
time honing their shooting and swimming skills.
By the time he returned to London, a stroke
of good luck befell Fleming.
In 1901, when he was 20 years old, he received
an inheritance of roughly 250 pounds from
his uncle, John Fleming.
It wasn’t a vast fortune or anything, but
it was enough for him to quit his 9-to-5 job
and continue his studies.
At the encouragement of his older brother
Tom who now had a thriving medical practice,
Fleming enrolled in med school.
There is a myth which is still popular today
which states that Fleming’s education was
paid for by the Churchill family because Fleming’s
father once saved Winston Churchill from drowning
as a boy.
In gratitude, Winston’s father, Lord Randolph
Churchill, promised to give young Alexander
the same kind of education that his own son
would receive.
The story continued decades later, during
World War II, when Churchill fell gravely
ill due to pneumonia, but his life was saved,
once again, by a Fleming thanks to the penicillin
developed by Alexander.
This is quite a fanciful tale and it most
likely still persists today because it involves
two popular, larger-than-life figures of their
time.
Unfortunately, there is no evidence to back
it up and Fleming himself dismissed it as
nothing but a “wondrous fable.”
There is nothing on the Churchill side to
lend it credence, either, and, as you might
suspect, the life of the prime minister has
been extensively documented.
The simple truth is that Fleming obtained
an inheritance and, because he had excellent
scores in his examinations, he could, more
or less, have his pick of colleges.
He chose St. Mary’s Hospital Medical School
in Paddington because it was close to his
home and because he once played water polo
against their team.
In 1906, he graduated from the school with
distinction and began his career in medical
research.
This was not his original choice and, in fact,
he made it through a strange set of circumstances.
At first, Fleming intended to become a surgeon.
As it happened, due to his time in the Boer
War, Alec was quite a skilled marksman and
one of the top shooters on St. Mary’s rifle
club team.
He was so valued, in fact, that the club captain
did not want him to leave which is what would
have happened if Fleming became a surgeon.
Instead, he convinced the Scotsman to pursue
a career in research at St. Mary’s and even
got him a position working under Sir Almroth
Wright.
That way everybody was happy - the rifle club
kept one of its top sharpshooters while Fleming
got to study under one of the world’s leading
immunologists.
Early Research
Here, Fleming was exposed to Wright’s ideas
on vaccine therapies which have, undoubtedly,
influenced his entire career.
In 1908 he graduated with a Bachelor of Science
degree in Bacteriology and became a lecturer
at St. Mary’s.
A few years later, Fleming developed a reputation
as the go-to guy in London if you were rich
and had syphilis.
He began administering Salvarsan, a new drug
which is known today as arsphenamine.
It was created in the lab of German physician
and Nobel Prize laureate Paul Ehrlich and,
back then, it was the first effective treatment
against syphilis.
Fleming was introduced to the drug by Wright
and amassed a tidy sum of money by being one
of the main proponents of Salvarsan in England.
Fleming’s practice and his research progressed
along smoothly until World War I broke out.
He enlisted and served with the Royal Army
Medical Corps as a captain.
During his time there, he continued his research
into bacteriology in a makeshift laboratory
in Boulogne, France.
He saw many soldiers die due to infected wounds
and couldn’t help but notice that the antiseptics
they were using tended to make the injuries
worse.
He studied this problem and wrote an article
which was subsequently published in the medical
journal The Lancet in 1917.
Fleming argued that chemicals such as carbolic
acid which were used as antiseptic were only
efficient in certain cases such as treating
surface cuts.
When dealing with deeper wounds, the chemicals
did more harm than good as they killed the
body’s own immunity agents such as leukocytes
and minimized its ability to protect itself
from infections.
According to his observations, anaerobic bacteria
thrived in deep wounds despite the presence
of antiseptics.
Fleming opined that, in such cases, it was
best to simply keep the wound clean and dry
and let nature take its course.
His beliefs were echoed by his mentor, Sir
Almroth Wright, who also argued that deep
wounds should only be cleaned using a simple
saline solution but, unfortunately, their
recommendations were mostly ignored by field
doctors for the rest of
the war.
The Discovery of Lysozyme
Even
though Fleming is renowned for his discovery
of penicillin, he actually made a different
breakthrough earlier in his career.
This one, however, did not end up having a
huge impact on medicine so it tends to get
left behind.
After he returned home from the war, Fleming
continued his studies into substances with
microbial properties and made an interesting
discovery while researching nasal mucus.
The exact circumstances are somewhat murky
as different versions of the story were repeated.
Some say he obtained the mucus sample from
a patient with a heavy cold.
Others say that Fleming himself was working
with a cold and had a “Eureka!” moment
and decided to investigate his own nasal drippings.
And some say that he simply got lucky and
a bit of his snot dripped down onto a Petri
dish while he was in the lab.
Regardless of how it got there, Fleming wanted
to see what effect the mucus would have on
bacteria.
He mixed the two together and let them sit
for a few weeks.
When he came back to investigate, Fleming
discovered that the nasal substance completely
killed the bacterial colonies.
Fleming realized that the secretion must have
contained an antimicrobial component which
was part of the human body’s innate immune
system.
It was an enzyme which Fleming isolated and
named lysozyme.
As he kept researching this new substance,
he found that it was present in many other
bodily secretions, including tears, saliva,
skin, and hair.
Subsequently, the bacteriologist discovered
that lysozyme was also present in egg whites
which meant that huge quantities could be
isolated with relative ease.
This could have been a major boon for the
field of immunology but, unfortunately, the
enzyme was mostly effective against harmless,
airborne bacteria rather than anything dangerous.
Today, it is mostly used as a food and wine
preservative.
Even so, it showed Fleming the potential in
this kind of research and set him on track
to make a discovery that will revolutionize
medicine forever.
Penicillin - A Fortuitous Accident
Fleming once wrote: “When I woke up just
after dawn on September 28, 1928, I certainly
didn’t plan to revolutionize all medicine
by discovering the world’s first antibiotic,
or bacteria killer.
But I suppose that was exactly what I did.”
The scientist was looking for a better alternative
to lysozyme.
The latter showed itself worthy as a proof
of concept, but surely there had to be another
substance out there somewhere which was more
efficient against dangerous bacteria.
To that end, Fleming had begun experimenting
and studying the properties of a bacterium
called staphylococcus, a nasty piece of work
that could cause abscesses, sore throats,
and boils.
Fortunately for Fleming (and the rest of the
world), the bacteriologist was not exactly
a tidy man.
In August 1928, he went on a family vacation
with his first wife, a nurse named Sarah McElroy,
and their only child, his 4-year-old boy named
Robert.
He grouped up all of his Petri dishes which
contained bacterial colonies and left them
near an open window in his lab.
In some versions of the story, this felicitous
carelessness was ascribed to one of his assistants,
not to Fleming himself.
When the doctor returned on September 3, he
noticed that one dish had been contaminated
with mold spores.
This annoyed him at first, but then he saw
that there were no bacterial colonies near
the mold.
The latter had killed all the bacteria it
came into contact with and inhibited its growth.
Fleming isolated the mold and identified it
as a rare strain of Penicillium notatum.
He gave his new creation the unfortunate name
of “mold juice” and it wasn’t until
several months later that he decided that
a rebranding might be in order and came up
with penicillin.
Unappealing name aside, Fleming’s “mold
juice” immediately showed great promise
as it proved effective not only against staphylococcus,
but other harmful bacteria such as meningococcus,
streptococcus, and the diphtheria bacillus.
The first antibiotic had been created and
the world now had a potential cure for pneumonia,
gonorrhea, meningitis, scarlet fever, and
other infectious diseases.
From Mold to Medicine
Actually, not so fast.
In reality, the process of taking penicillin
and turning it from a simple mold into a practical
medicine was long and difficult and involved
a lot of work from many different scientists.
Fleming’s role is undeniable, but to give
him sole credit for ushering in the era of
antibiotics is doing a disservice to many
other brilliant minds.
First off, let’s talk a bit about his precursors.
Fleming was the first to isolate and identify
the bacteria-killing mold and treat other
people with it, but the phenomenon itself
had been around for millennia.
Ancient cultures like the Egyptians were noted
for the practice of applying poultices made
from moldy bread on wounds to prevent infections.
In modern times, an English physician named
Sir John Burdon-Sanderson might have been
the first to observe and report that certain
molds from the Penicillium family could inhibit
the growth of bacteria back in 1871.
Inspired by his work, Joseph Lister, the father
of antiseptic surgery, established a year
later that Penicillium glaucum had the potential
to kill off bacteria, but never published
his findings.
Many other scientists came before the Scottish
doctor but, for whatever reasons, they were
never able to take their own research to conclusion.
Even Fleming himself found it difficult, at
first, to make others care about his discovery.
In 1928, he isolated the mold, he called it
penicillin and began treating people with
it.
In June of the following year, Fleming published
his findings in The British Journal of Experimental
Pathology to a very lukewarm and uninterested
reception.
Back then, people could not yet see how antibiotics
could change the medical world and this included
Fleming himself.
In the article, he made few mentions regarding
penicillin’s potential medical applications
and, instead, focused on how it could be used
in a mixed culture to separate bacteria sensitive
to the mold from bacteria that had no reaction
to it.
The main problem was that Fleming discovered
early on how difficult it was to work with
penicillin.
He had two assistants, Stuart Craddock and
Frederick Ridley, who were given the arduous
task of finding ways to isolate pure penicillin
from the fungus which produced it.
However, the substance was unstable and they
were only able to produce solutions of crude
material.
For a while, it looked like manufacturing
large quantities of penicillin would have
been nigh-impossible.
The Long Road to the Nobel Prize
During the 1930s, Fleming continued his research
on penicillin, but never made that breakthrough
that would have turned it into the life-saving
drug we know today.
The same problems remained all throughout
the decade - the penicillin was too impure
and could not be mass produced.
That breakthrough did happen, eventually,
but it came from a team at Oxford led by Australian
pharmacologist Howard Florey.
His group worked in a research department
named the Sir William Dunn School of Pathology,
better known simply as the Dunn School.
They started their work on penicillin in 1939,
with the main goal being to isolate and stabilize
enough of it to be usable on humans.
Besides Florey, some of the other key members
of the Oxford team were German biochemist
Ernst Chain, English biologist Norman Heatley
and English biochemist Edward Abraham.
However, their program needed so much penicillium
mold filtrate for animal experiments and clinical
trials that, soon enough, pretty much the
entire Dunn School worked on the project so
we could never fully give credit to everyone
who played a part in developing the life-saving
antibiotic.
Their efforts were also slowed down by another
“minor issue” called World War II so it
wasn’t like they had an abundance of manpower
and resources.
In fact, to save on space and materials, they
began growing bacteria cultures in whatever
vessels they had on hand such as bathtubs,
food tins, and even bedpans.
Edward Abraham correctly deduced the structure
of penicillin, at roughly the same time as
American chemist Robert Burns Woodward.
Norman Heatley suggested that larger volumes
of penicillin could be produced by extracting
it into amyl acetate and then back into water.
Chain and Florey discovered how to isolate
and concentrate the germ-killing agent found
in penicillin.
In 1940, the team used penicillin to protect
mice from streptococcus.
A year later, a policeman named Albert Alexander
became the first human to receive the Oxford
penicillin in order to treat a bad infection
he had inside his mouth.
Although Alexander made a quick recovery in
just a few days, they didn’t have enough
of the drug to deal with the infection completely
and it returned in a few days and killed him.
Not an auspicious start, but subsequent patients
fared better and showed the world the value
of penicillin as medicine.
The challenge of scaling up production of
the drug to industrial quantities was eventually
taken up by British and American pharmaceutical
companies, particularly the Northern Regional
Research Laboratory (NRRL) in Peoria, Illinois,
a subsidiary of the United States Department
of Agriculture.
As you can see, there were many individuals
and institutions that played a vital role
in the development of penicillin as an antibiotic.
For their work, they were awarded the Nobel
Prize in Physiology or Medicine in 1945, although
it only recognized Alexander Fleming, Howard
Florey, and Ernst Chain due to one of the
foundation’s most controversial rules of
awarding a Nobel Prize to a maximum of three
people.
Later Years
Fleming spent his entire professional career
as a researcher at St. Mary’s and, in 1946,
succeeded his mentor Almroth Wright as head
of the hospital’s Inoculation Department
which was renamed to the Wright-Fleming Institute.
He also served as President of the Society
for General Microbiology, rector of Edinburgh
University, a member of the Pontifical Academy
of Science, and even as Honorary Chief Doy-gei-tau
of the Native American Kiowa tribe.
In addition to these, Fleming also received
pretty much every honorary medal and doctorate
and award and all other scientific honors
under the sun.
For his part, Fleming always made sure to
acknowledge the efforts of Florey and his
team in making penicillin a worldwide commodity,
but the general public and the media seemed
determined to lavish their praise solely on
the Scottish microbiologist, probably because
the story of his “happy accident” was
more enjoyable.
In his later years, Fleming concentrated his
efforts on warning people about a problem
that we face right now - resistance to antibiotics.
Both he and Almroth Wright realized early
on that microbes could very easily become
resistant to penicillin if the wrong doses
were used or for too short a period, with
each subsequent generation of microorganisms
being more resistant than the last.
He wrote several papers on the matter and
even mentioned it during his speech for the
Nobel Prize.
In his private life, Fleming was quiet and
unassuming.
His son Robert followed in his father’s
footsteps, studied medicine and became a general
practitioner.
His first wife, Sarah, passed away in 1949
and, unsurprisingly, this had a profound effect
on Fleming who buried himself in his work
and spent a lot of time alone, in his laboratory,
until the late hours of the night.
Fleming’s life brightened up considerably
when he met Dr. Amalia Koutsouri-Vourekas
who came to work at St. Mary’s.
The two fell in love and married in 1953,
but their happiness was short-lived.
Alexander Fleming died suddenly two years
later, on March 11, 1955, of coronary thrombosis.
He had been feeling poorly over the last few
weeks, but was convinced that it was only
gastric distress.
When he started feeling nauseous on the day
of his death, his wife wanted to call a doctor,
but he insisted that it wasn’t necessary.
He had a heart attack minutes later and was
subsequently buried at St Paul’s Cathedral.
Alexander Fleming’s life may have been extinguished
in moments, but he left behind a life-saving
legacy that will live on forever, one that
few people in history could ever hope
to match.